[Music]
[Music]
one
[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen gentlemen
[Laughter]
yeah this is we're doing um sisters a
movie called sisters which tila
told me to watch this one that's
probably we'll see what ended up
bitching showing up where are you two
what ended up happening with this it's
weird because i was actually gonna do
because you know i have my flickers of
fear show which is you know movies
reviews that i do by myself
and this was actually the next one that
i was going to record and then when
somebody mentioned it when tila
mentioned in the comments it said like
margo kidd or was it you're like oh well
i want to watch that too
yeah so i was like well okay we'll just
do it on the matinee show we can watch
it together
and then you know i'll just pick another
movie to do for my other
uh movie review it's a pretty good movie
i've never seen it before
yeah i saw it probably five or six years
ago for the person kind of like alfred
hitchcock movie it's kind of like
psycho or or not really psycho mixed
with a bunch of other stuff
it's got hypnotism in it inside these
twins and
margo kidder and murders and margot
looks great in it she looks really good
she's pretty young in this yeah this was
before black christmas eve yeah
she did a couple of nude scenes in it
she was looking good bad i mean she's
thin a little too thin for me i like i
like [ __ ]
kind of stocky muscular kind of like but
she's
pretty stacked in it for what it was i
mean by the time she's lois lane she's
just too goddamn skinny i mean that
cocaine i guess just turned her tearing
her up
but at least she looks female in this
you know
i mean i feel like i feel like the kokor
thing was like a big
thing in the 70s everyone had to be so
thin that they could get into those like
really super tight pants that i didn't
know how people breathed in them but
she's cute in it she's got a damn french
accent and a bunch of bad [ __ ] happens
and then you find out all kinds of stuff
and then this happens and that dude died
another dude saw it and it got attracted
thank you that was a very very good plot
yeah you guys know exactly what i'm
called
i thought then tila shows up what's up
just talking about it where's that [ __ ]
i did this move we reviewed this movie
because you told me to
yeah because i was gonna i was gonna
review it by myself but you so you
wanted to see it because margaret kitter
was there yeah even t saying that margot
looked great at it yeah
ever since i was a kid you know what i
mean if i can
look at that woman you know it's [ __ ]
she was cute man there was just
something kind of
vaguely kind of weird kind of [ __ ]
about her now
when i say that it's like a 70s or 80s
[ __ ]
which i just met that was a woman who
owned her sexuality you know it wasn't
the way we used to those we use those
words maybe not
how you'd use it today didn't mean that
she's just [ __ ] everybody you know or
just that didn't really mean that just
meant
sexually powerful well i think that was
that's why she was my favorite
uh character in black christmas just
because she was like a drunk
[ __ ] and she didn't give a [ __ ] yeah and
she was just like making dirty jokes at
everybody yeah it was like
yeah that's who that's the girl i want
to hang out with yeah you don't want to
hang out with a good girl
no it wasn't even like that right
yeah good girls no i wanted the bad one
you wanted the bad one that was the one
that was going to be
a lot more fun yeah yeah well yeah so
yeah so like i said this movie actually
came out a couple years before black
christmas this came in 1972
yeah um so this is directed uh famously
by brian de palma i feel like it's kind
of one of his lesser known ones because
it's like four years before carrie
and i feel like that was kind of his big
uh breakout you know
yeah um so that hurt said tom my ears
were burning yeah
because you were talking about talking
about you yeah louie said yeah she was
getting kids drunk i know that was one
of my favorite parts i'm like look at
her contributing to the delinquent minor
you naughty you naughty girl yeah she
hunt
first thing she does it with her with
her [ __ ] [ __ ] french accent is
[ __ ]
hook up with a [ __ ] good-looking
light-skinned black dude
but he's like a man of honor and [ __ ]
you know
well yeah like i said this movie's super
old so like if you haven't seen it like
sorry but
yeah so i i feel like well brian de
palma i i feel like a lot of people like
[ __ ] on because they're like oh well
he's just like a hitchcock copyist but
he never made a secret of that he was
like a big huge fan of hitchcock
and he actually made this movie in
particular
um as an homage to hitchcock he used
bernard herrmann
who famously did the re read the psycho
score uh did the score for this
even though he was semi semi-retired at
the time and there
a lot of um shots in it are direct
homages
to other hitchcock movies like you know
from vertigo
there's one the scene where uh philip
the guy that she kills
you know he's kind of crawling through
the whole apartment like leaving a trail
of blood or whatever like this really
long like tracking shot
um i think that he that was like his
homage to rope
which is another hitchcock movie so he
he didn't make a secret about
i'm making this as an itch as a
hitchcock homage but
it's still a great movie in its own
right it's like it just has
i don't know there's just something
really about this one that appeals to me
i'm not sure what it is you know what
i'm saying
yeah well to me it's just i'm looking at
it's a good movie but i'm just looking
at margo kidder just bringing back it's
just bringing back memories you know
what i mean that's like he just got
distracted and he didn't even like pay
attention to what was going on
she looked like one of those chicks that
you'd find when i'm old [ __ ] porn
rags we used to dig up out of [ __ ]
garbage when we were kids
[ __ ] like what was it stag magazine
yeah or [ __ ]
high society and [ __ ] back in [ __ ]
1981.
she just looked like that you know what
i mean just yeah
you guys had to be there to understand
some of you guys who are old enough to
who who remember those
times you know you know what it is i'm
talking about there's just something
kind of illicit about the way they
looked
the way they where they acted it's
it's a lost art it's a lost art yeah
it's a lot yeah but yeah
so yeah interestingly i thought this was
kind of an interesting choice so margot
kidder
plays a french canadian
model in this with the french accent and
everything
and the thing about it is well marco
kidder is canadian
yeah um she's not french-canadian though
i don't see she's not from quebec i
don't think but she's from another part
of canada
so i'm guessing the french accent was
fake but i thought it was okay
dude i said tom got bhubatized yeah a
little bit yeah yeah a little bit i was
like wait but hold on she's different
this one she got a little bit of weight
on her and then like uh
then they're talking about the penthouse
penthouse was always the one to go that
wouldn't hustler no i was thinking even
below a couple rungs you know like stag
remember that one velvet
they have one called velvet this is
[ __ ] crazy yeah that sounds vaguely
yeah we
magazine remember that that [ __ ] went
all out of business i think by the time
the 90s had come around
well yeah because we had the internet
vhs started to [ __ ] appear yeah
yeah yeah but yeah so this was actually
i guess brian de palma got the idea for
this from a real life case of siamese
twins like canada's first siamese
they were russian i think um you know
for from the soviet union
and i guess he had seen a photograph of
them which i think he tried to recreate
a little bit for this
movie like with margo kidder like it was
on some of the um promotional material
and it was in the movie as well
with like one of the sisters sitting
there looking ahead and smiling and
looking all happy and everything and
then the other one kind of over here
looking all grouchy and
evil and [ __ ] so he said it was a really
striking image and it kind of like stuck
in his head
so he used that image as sort of like
the idea
behind uh this movie
so what they're laughing they're
bringing up all the old magazines so
they're talking about
sherry magazine and [ __ ] [ __ ] i
remember that [ __ ] they're all they're
all bringing it they're remembering it
no needs goes yeah the trailer park type
girl said yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's it that's yeah and then
after says my boyfriend had those
magazines
then louie goes remember you guys
remember biggins magazine
jugs that was another i remember yeah i
remember seeing like jug sometimes like
in the
in the cause sometimes depending on the
convenience store you went to
like most of them was under the counter
but some of them would just put them
behind the counter because they didn't
give you
yeah so sometimes you go buy some gum or
something yeah
by having we in penthouse in the tree
fort underneath underneath the [ __ ]
underneath the carpets and stuff yeah we
stash them [ __ ] things
yeah i feel like out all the boys that
grew up at the in that yeah
did that because dudes were throwing
them out [ __ ] we were going through
the older you know [ __ ] growing men
were throwing them things out [ __ ] we
and we'd go through the trash try to
find them yeah because that's what you
did when you were a kid
well yeah like you find a whole jack
jackpot you know [ __ ] like 57 of them
and [ __ ]
i've heard from several dudes that grew
up in that time yeah they all kind of
had the same experiences
man there was all kind of dudes like
throwing yeah magazines out in the woods
well maybe because they knew it's like
i'll throw that out there for the kids
will find it yeah
well you're like seven or eight you're
looking at it you're like seven or eight
you're looking for the things
that's what they're doing you're talking
about all these you're all this [ __ ]
sexualizing those kids well you didn't
grow up in the 70s
well you had to learn about [ __ ]
somewhere yeah back in seven
70s was worse yeah yeah it was well
worse
in quotations it was better it was more
realistic it was more
well in some i don't know in some ways
it was worse in some ways it's better
well we weren't locked up
yeah we grew up outside tila said who
would have thought that the movie
sisters would have dudes going down porn
mag memory land
i can't even talk about the movie okay
guys comment section needs to straighten
the [ __ ] up
straighten the [ __ ] up i mean if you
don't want me to talk about the movie i
won't no
i'm just saying i'm not blaming it all
on the comment section yeah
you just cause like i said i was going
to review this by myself but no you
wouldn't chill the [ __ ] out you were the
ones that said
get your mind out of the gutter you
wanted to watch it so [ __ ]
what i forgot what forgot what my
injections got to take an injection
today i'll be all right
well it's all right it's okay we'll get
around it
you'll be fine okay i promise
yeah well you should have thought of
that earlier well you got all day
we had to work yeah well you know you
got all those okay
you don't have it i just got to rig it
up you shoot it yeah so
the story behind this one as i said that
uh you know so margo kidder is playing
danielle who's a french canadian
model at the very beginning of the show
she's on this
uh tv show like this cheesy ass tv show
it's kind of like candid camera
but it's called like peeping tom right
and uh while she's on this show
she meets uh phillip who's this dude and
she thinks he's like super foxy or
whatever
so they kind of go out to dinner and
then they go back to her apartment
meanwhile her creepy supposedly
ex-husband emil is like following them
around like all the way back to staten
island on the [ __ ] ferry because
that's where this was shot staten island
in new york
and uh so philip's a little freaked out
but
he kind of like misdirects they get a
meal to go away so the two of them bang
now the next morning you're not really
entirely sure at first like what the
[ __ ] is going on with danielle right
because she gets up out of bed she seems
a little
out of sorts you're like well maybe
she's just hungover from the night
before because she was super drunk
she's taken some medication then you
hear her talking to somebody else in
french in another room and you presume
that this is her twin sister
dominique who she's been talking about
before so philip overhears this
and then um he's like oh she's like oh
it's our birthday and it's like she's
usually in the mental asylum but they
said that she could come visit me today
because it was the birthday
and now she's pissed off that you're
here and blah blah so he goes
to the pharmacy to get her uh to pick up
her prescription because i guess that
was a thing you could do back then you
could just pick up
random drugs for people and then he's he
decides to be a nice
dude and so he goes cc's a bakery and he
gets them a birthday cake
and puts both their names on it only
problem is when he gets back to the
apartment
um apparently dominique is now in the
apartment
and she stabs his ass now a complicating
factor arises because he doesn't die
right away and he's just like crawling
through the apartment
and he actually manages to get up to a
window
and write like help me on it in his
blood like before he dies
and the woman across the courtyard in
the other apartment
um whose name is grace collier she's
like a newspaper reporter yeah she's
another cutie
and she sees it although her hair in
this is terrible yeah
what were they thinking well i cuz what
was she thinking i
i'd feel like a lot of women that was
70s porn yeah it had
it was almost like a mullet sort of yeah
it was just like that
shag because i kind of feel like when i
was little because my great aunt was a
hairdresser
and so she always used to come over my
grandma's house and she used to cut all
her hair like all her kids hair
and i feel like she did that to my hair
a few times in the 70s
like that that kind of shag sort of [ __ ]
it says 70s porn here i was talking
about kind of like the old dorothy
hamill haircuts remember those look like
a [ __ ] top of a circumcised dick
it did i never had that yeah but i for
sure had
now the hair that gen the actress
jennifer salt has in this
i had hair kind of similar to that i
think when i was seven or eight years
old mushroom head
i mean who would have thought like who
thought that looked good
i guess it was kind of cute until you
[ __ ] looked closely at it for too
long
yeah it did yeah it does
she was [ __ ] funny i couldn't figure
out how it worked like just the
logistics of it
like i was like how do you even because
i can't get my hair to do [ __ ]
honestly so they didn't curl it
underneath it
yeah it's like what does that look like
when you wake up i never had hair like
that so i don't really know like
because i'm sure you really have to like
maintain that [ __ ]
which is probably why i never had it
done because it looked like i like hair
that you can just wake up and it looks
passable you know what i mean that's
just that's why i just keep it easy it's
just kind of like
parted in the middle with bangs because
it's like kind of hard to mess that up
but um but yeah so so she ends up
stabbing his ass the woman across the
thing
like sees it and she runs over
and is trying to like get uh danielle
into trouble she doesn't know danielle
but i mean you know so she's
but the cops don't want to listen to her
ironically well i don't know if it's
ironic but
because grace has written a lot of kind
of anti-cop [ __ ] like in the
papers so the cops are just kind of like
man [ __ ] you [ __ ] whatever you're just
like making stuff up
but the the sad thing is that grace is
right like there is a dead guy in the
apartment but what happened was that
danielle
said oh dominique was here and she did
it and she seems to be acting like
different like she didn't
she didn't realize what was going on
emil comes over and they hide the body
in a sort of genius place in the [ __ ]
hide-a-bed in the couch
and i was just kind of like hey they
don't call that a hide-a-bed for nothing
that's a pretty clever uh place to hide
it
and honestly i liked this part of the
movie a lot because you know how brian
de palma like uses um
all that split screen like he didn't
carry he does it all the time that's
kind of
one of his motifs and i thought that was
like a really great
um okay
bye what was that all about i don't know
this my phone was ringing um
stop calling we're doing a goddamn [ __ ]
i don't know what it was
it wasn't anybody it was from somebody
from daytona or i don't know it was a
daytona area number
it's one of your other boyfriends yes
yeah all the boyfriends that i have he
held his boyfriend's yes
[Laughter]
you
she doesn't need any other ones well
that's what i'm saying that's what that
see that's why i would never like do it
so i'm like look dude one is more than
enough all right it's like i don't
i got one child you're hard enough to
deal with i don't need more at the top
dude
it's too much trouble but yeah no yeah
well no it's true though no
yeah absolutely i'm serious go ahead go
ahead probably want you to let you know
your car warranty is expiring that's
probably exactly what it was
oh my god tila said you know what i
didn't notice this
tila said i noticed the actor who played
a meal was the lead in phantom of the
paradise holy [ __ ] she loved us
i thought he looked familiar
that's right we were calling him the
[ __ ] uh uh
john waters [ __ ] yeah i said he looked
like a john waters [ __ ] well
because he had that little teeny weird
like
uh pedo stash
[Laughter]
but yeah so so i love like the whole
split screen
with grace like arguing with the cops in
the lobby
and meanwhile emil and danielle are like
trying to hide the body and clean up the
apartment and everything
and it's just so good like the [ __ ]
because you can see both of them going
on at the same time finally like the
cops drag their asses up there
and danielle is to is acting totally
totally cool
you know nothing happened blah blah blah
it's like they can't find anything even
though there's like a blood stain on the
back of the couch that they miss but the
cops don't see it
now grace suspects that they're going
she doesn't think danielle killed
anybody but she thinks danielle is
covering for somebody else
and so she goes she kind of like snoops
around the apartment like while the cops
aren't looking
and she finds that birthday cake in the
fridge that says danielle and dominique
on and she's like aha
you know what i mean i've got it and
then she comes out in the [ __ ] living
room and then she slips on the [ __ ] that
emil was using to like clean the floor
and the cake gets all [ __ ] up so
she gets like totally gas-lit through
this whole thing even though she's
correct
even though danielle uh
or dominique did kill somebody yeah hey
tila did you uh did you see a repo
genetic opera
oh yeah he's gonna keep bugging you
about he's blocking it because i kept up
my end of the bargain
[ __ ] [ __ ] she didn't see that [ __ ] i
got you [ __ ]
well like i said you got to give people
some time there's only so many hours in
the day
right because like i said i got tons of
[ __ ] i got to watch and read and [ __ ]
like that and i don't i just don't have
time to do
i got yeah i don't have time to do it
all but yeah so
so grace becomes convinced that she is
correct that that body is somewhere
and she's going to write a story about
it so she starts her own investigation
because the cops are basically like man
shut up there's nothing going on
so she gets like a private investigator
of the newspaper gets a private
investigator played by charles derning
of all people
and uh he kind of breaks into the
apartment and uh
finds the thing about the twins now
as they kind of go through the story so
it's basically like a murder mystery at
first but then you find out
because you think that danielle's twin
sister who has gone back to the mental
asylum was the one that committed the
murder
but it turns out that um
danielle did have a siamese twin
and they were separated actually quite
recently i think it was like less than a
year before
but dominique died during that uh
operation to separate them uh emil was
the guy
that separated them he was like the
doctor and
since dominique died i guess danielle
has sort of internalized
her sister and is is essentially like
being both the sisters so but
so she killed phillip but she doesn't
remember
it because she like dissociates you know
what i'm saying yeah
so yeah so you have that kind of thing
going on like this whole siamese twin
thing the whole
murder mystery thing and there's also
like some [ __ ] at the end
which cause remember how i was saying
like grace she knew she because she saw
like philip in the window and he was
celebrating help me in his blood and she
actually saw
the woman stabbing him right so she's
like reporting the police and they don't
believe her because when they get up to
the apartment there's like nothing going
on up there
and so she you know investigates herself
but then in the course of the
investigation
she ends up going to this mental
hospital where emil still works
and she goes in there trying to like
confront him or whatever
and then emile says that she's another
patient
and so no one believes her then either
and then he ends up drugging her
and hypnotizing her and giving her a
post-hypnotic suggestion
that she never saw the body yeah and it
works
yeah tito's gotta read tina's comment
where is it
at the top repo not yet but i did see
legend of boggy creek made in 72 oh my
god so cheesy or bad
i'm scared to see the second one we just
did a review of his first movie boggy
creek just right
no not boggy because we did uh telling
the dreaded thunder yeah we just
recorded it before we did the show yeah
she said repo is up for tonight yeah and
uh
we we did mention um the boggy creek
series
yeah i don't remember the first boggy
creek
the one yeah i vaguely remember it it's
the second one
that i that i like i kind of liked it um
the sound town that dreaded sundown we
saw that last night
it's actually a competent movie it's a
lot better than the buggy creek movies
it's pretty good it's based on a real
case yeah it's like i said it's based on
the phantom killer of texarkana which we
did a show about a long time ago
yeah those are all serious and murders
no i'd watch repo
overwatch in boggy creek but [ __ ]
boggy creek 2
is the better well like i said if you're
going to watch boggy creek 2
watch the mystery science theater
version yeah yeah it's much fun it's
much easier to watch yeah with people
making jokes about
it yeah because they're kind of boring
by today's standards to edit
they're kind of long and well not really
long they're
there's a lot of dead space in them [ __ ]
that could you could put jokes in there
riffing on it and you and you know it's
a lot better when somebody's riffing on
it
yeah all of them all those old movies
are
well that's why they usually end up
doing like a lot of the older ones
because they had these kind of like gaps
and
yeah a lot of gaps and stuff yeah she
said the first baggie is like a
mockumentary yeah it's a like town that
dried it sundown is a little bit like
that too but
but that's actually based on well i mean
i guess you could argue that legend of
boggy creek is technically
based on a real it's based on a real
legend yeah like the
whatever but the legend isn't real it
was made up to keep black people out of
there well yeah we mentioned that before
but it's based on the what did we did we
figure out how to pronounce that the
falc monster fook monster monster
folk probably folk folk it's f-o-u-k-e
folk yeah poke it looks like falc
mississippi you'd say folk y'all don't
know how to pronounce [ __ ]
well it might might actually be
f-o-l-k you you pronounce that folk also
and you could spell it that way
it might be yeah but f o u k e
folk seems like it should be falc no
folk or fuch if it was french not in
redneck
and that would be the same thing as
f-o-l-k folk
folk milky folk that's probably what it
is
i feel like they're naming it after a
man well i i
imagine that probably it is named after
a person's last name right
um and i remember like dan bell did a
show
about that about that monster that the
boggy creek creature was based on
and they and he like asked them how they
pronounced it but now i can't remember
because it was so long ago that i saw it
yeah yeah it's arkansas it's that tila
yeah
it's arkansas in the deep deep parts of
the south you just
you just pronounce things the way that
it's most comfortable comfortable for
you
you know what i'm talking about there's
no method to any of that well and just
hope that other people know what the
hell you're talking about anyway
they're all doing that they're probably
not they're all doing that too
yeah but yeah so uh
getting back to what we were talking
about so i kind of feel like the movie
sisters
is sort of like a forgot it's got a
criterion collection uh
[ __ ] now too because like i said it's
brian to paul man it's one of his
earlier ones
and uh that's what we watched we saw it
on amazon prime we rented it i think it
was 3.99
and that was like the criterion
collection uh you know
version and it looks really nice like i
said i love all the split screen [ __ ]
i love all the hitchcock homages i
especially like the [ __ ] toward the end
once grace gets to the mental hospital
and
she gets hypnotized and then there's
that whole really weird sequence where
they're essentially telling the story of
what happened
with danielle and dominique and them
being separated
and it was this whole thing where
danielle wanted to was married to a meal
but you know it's kind of awkward being
a siamese twin and being married to
somebody and it's just kind of like you
have to wait for the siamese twin to
fall asleep so y'all can have sex
or whatever so i guess that danielle got
pregnant and
dominique got jealous and killed the
baby like stabbed her with garden shears
or something like that
and at which point danielle was kind of
like can we just get rid of this [ __ ]
i'm sick of having her hanging off my
hip all the time so he separated them
and then
dominique died but then danielle kind of
went crazy
but this they they do it in this whole
weird
dream sequence where grace
is i guess he's she's like drugged and
hypnotized and she's
seeing herself in dominique's position
and it's really cool it's like i really
really like that sequence it's like
really creepy he said that he got the
idea for doing that from the
from the um part from rosemary's baby
like where she was getting raped by
satan you know what i mean like that
weird dream sequence yeah
he said that's where he got the idea for
doing that it's like all in black and
white
and like all these people that she knows
like keep turning up there's like all
these kind of sideshow performers in the
background for whatever reason
well not for whatever reason that's you
know because siamese twins
slide shows so there's that kind of
whole thing going she sees people she
knows in the background and it's kind of
like
you know the the one part where they're
gonna separate them and then like
there's a cleaver
and like all the dudes around like
passing the cleaver from one another
then he's like chopping them in half and
[ __ ]
it's like really really freaky i was i
think that's like a really good uh
nightmare sequence in that one and i
also love
love the end the last shot of the movie
because like i said you know they they
hid phillips body in the couch right
now danielle does get her comeuppance
because she kills emil
um you know and that's like witnessed so
she gets arrested for that
and they still suspect that then finally
the cops come around and be like oh
sorry grace i guess she is a murderer
like you know sorry we
gas let you this whole movie but um but
by that point grace has been you know
hypnotized and she doesn't remember the
murder anymore
so that's no help there and then they
show at the beginning at the end
the couch that had the body in it they
actually had some movers take it and
they left it like at this [ __ ] remote
ass
train station in canada somewhere and
like the very last scene is like this
[ __ ] couch just and there's like a
cow comes up and like looks at
it and then but then you see like the
private investigator like up on a
[ __ ] light pole or whatever like
looking down at it through binoculars
so i guess like he was still following
up on the [ __ ] because he said i'm gonna
follow that couch because i think that's
where the body is
because they did figure out that that's
where the body was because the couch got
taken out
yeah tina the town that dreaded sundown
uh has been remastered it looks a lot
better than the boggy creek movies
um that was on uh we saw that on um
amazon wouldn't it amazon prime didn't
that have talent
no we we watched a free version on
youtube oh that was a youtube version
okay because remember it's weird because
we went on
okay so i mean we i don't want to talk
too much about town the dreaded sundown
because we just did a whole
yeah and that's coming up tomorrow right
no um well for patrons it'll be thursday
for everybody else every friday
okay that's when it's going on um but
and i but i don't think we mentioned
this on the recording that
it said that it was on amazon prime but
then when i went on amazon prime
it had the trailer but then it said this
is not available that's right
so i was like well that's me and so then
i went up but then i went on youtube
and you maybe you could have rented it
on youtube i'm not sure but then i saw
somebody had posted it for free
um and it was a beautiful beautiful
version like a wide screen
like it looked fantastic looks about
like a um
1960s late 60s television program kind
of
um it comparable actually in quality to
like
the first two friday the 13th
real similar yeah i liked it it did have
it did have some flaws and imperfections
we talked about it in
in the upcoming review yeah but you can
see it for free
yeah as far as i know unless copyright
got taken i'd say it was better than
better than the boggy creek movies but
buggy creek 2 is pretty
fun it's terrible but it's
yeah it's fun it's fun [ __ ] happens in
it but you gotta
but like she said if if you're listening
to mst version they're riffing which
makes it even better
and that is actually one of the best
episodes i think right
i i really like i i like when they did
kind of 70s and 80s movies and i like
when they did kind of like rednecky
yeah like hick movies yeah so like this
one and the one uh the giant spider
invasion which was shot in wisconsin
yeah um we're actually mike who's like
the head writer he's from wisconsin
so he got a lot of uh he got a lot of
digs in there too so i thought that was
like super fun as well
um plus you know there's there's a lot
of uh comedic potential in a giant
spider that's
clearly made out of a vw bug with carpet
[Laughter]
and it's clearly shoving its victims up
its ass up its butt yeah which which
they did actually make
well i love servo's comment it's like um
it's like should we be alarmed that this
diner the spider is stuffing them up his
butt
yeah because that's exactly
[Laughter]
is that once it gets big enough the
spider
it actually does as a practical effect
run down the middle of the [ __ ] town
it's huge but it's clearly like a
volkswagen bug
yeah it's like with a [ __ ] float of a
shape like a spider on top of it with
its [ __ ]
they were probably so excited when they
thought of that
you guys you can clearly have to do
a [ __ ] volkswagen underneath who's
got a vw bug oh i've got one
can i glue carpet all over it and then
like put big [ __ ] legs it's like look
we can even use the headlights for eyes
it'll be awesome yeah it's [ __ ] funny
that'll be awesome
and my dad took me to see that in the
theater when it came out and it scared
the [ __ ] out of me
especially when she drank the [ __ ]
tarantula out of the blender
even stephen king mentioned that scene
in dance macabre yeah
it's funny because he's like even though
that film is like just
stupid um it's like but that scene
because
in that moment you can relate to that
happening to you
like a sp a big juicy tarantula crawling
into your [ __ ] smoothie and in your
blender
there's another drinking it without
knowing and there's a bunch of like
kinky hillbilly sexual innuendos and
incest going
going on yeah that was also baffling
yeah
hillbilly dude big old fat hillbilly
dude with like a hot
wife and he's trying to screw the hot
wife's
sister i think it's her younger sister
younger sister and they're running
around and cuddling she's like she's
like a teenager she's like 17.
yeah and they're running around in
cut-offs and the old dude is wearing
like a
truss or a back brace yourself that it's
super gross
i don't remember it exactly i remember
the [ __ ] girls wearing [ __ ] like
cutoffs and [ __ ] tube tops and there
was like butt cheeks hanging out from
underneath the phone yeah it was
definitely cut offs and i think they
were kind of like this little halter
tied like right on above your navel yeah
i think it was that
free air conditioning [ __ ] hillbilly
clothing yeah like i said it was shot in
wisconsin
yeah do you know i remember the guy that
made that movie
and that was the disgusting guy with the
back brace yeah
that guy was in the loved one you
remember he was in that one scene and i
was like hey it's that guy from uh
because because later he's like a um
what do you what do you call it he's a
dialect
coach okay he became a dialect coach
later on
that was him yeah yeah that was what it
was yeah it's like and if you
heard him talk because we were watching
the loved one again and i had forgotten
that he was he's only like in one scene
yeah and as soon as he talked the the
only thing i could think of was you've
been hitting the booze again
i think i even said that cause i was
like that's from giant spider invasion
but yeah it wasn't it wasn't a little 17
or running around he's smacking her in
the ass in front of
yeah it was super inappropriate in front
of her sister or something
yeah it's weird and like it's gonna be
it's it's definitely an homage to some
kind of weird incest stuff going on also
alan hale
yeah yeah yeah and he was making kind of
jokes about
pooping and or like prunes and stuff so
he's going to see mystery science
theater
yeah it's much easier to sit through if
you watch this
video an mst's version of [ __ ] giant
spider invasion this movie
i've seen the mst version like a million
times and we also saw the rip tracks
live version which is also very funny
which is all different jokes you want to
throw in [ __ ] birdemic and mano's
hands of fate
too those [ __ ] are awesome that was
rip
tracks wasn't it that was rough driving
tracks yeah which is the same guys but
under a different brand yeah it's pretty
much the same guys yeah i mean not as
the new
new mst but you know the the sci-fi era
ones
um yeah so pat was asking uh about
sisters he's like did you think that
grace was actually the twin and that
this whole thing was about i don't know
it's i guess
i guess you can make an argument but i
thought my interpretation of it was
because emil drugged her with something
and they don't tell you what it is it
was just something that was in a um
you know a syringe and then he
hypnotizes her and gives her that
post-hypnotic suggestion that she didn't
see the murder and that there was no
body
um and that's all that she would
remember about it so he like wiped her
memory of it essentially
and i just kind of figured because he
says to her like while she's hypnotized
you know i'll show you what happened or
so i just assumed that he was telling
her
what happened with danielle and
dominique and them getting separated and
everything
and then she was like nightmarishly like
projecting it like in her mind like it
was a movie that's kind of
the interpretation that i had about it i
mean you know i could i could be wrong
but that's kind of how i read it i don't
know
but um yeah there was it's weird there
was a lot of like i said it's
it's very hitchcockian in the sense that
um there's a lot of like voyeurist
voyeuristic type of stuff in it like
even the even the game show at the
beginning
is called peeping tom and it's all about
like watching people doing [ __ ] and like
guessing what they're gonna do
and then like you know it's like people
watching through windows watching
through binoculars
it's like it's all that kind of stuff so
it's kind of like which which like i
said i feel like that was a real
hitchcockian thing as well yeah it's a
good movie
uh but it's a movie of its time it has a
hitchcock tone and edit
which uh by the day some younger viewers
may not enjoy that but
you know if you're a little older and
you grew and you have more more diverse
tastes in
cinema you know you'll understand it
they're all kind of
longer than they have to be but that was
just the way
movies were you know yeah
and they're not like disneyland rides
where it's just jam-packed action
through [ __ ]
two hours like they are now well the
thing about it is that you
can't i kind of feel like too that if
you
l and i've said this before if you're
gonna watch a movie like at least invest
your
time and attention in watching the movie
and i'm not saying
that movies you know can't be
action-packed or they have to be super
slow
i'm just saying that for scenes of
action or horror or whatever to have any
impact
you have to have the calm before the
storm essentially you can't just come in
and just be like
you know stab stab stab kill kill kill
it's like nobody would care because it's
like i don't care
i don't know who these characters are
who gives a [ __ ] if they get stabbed
it's you know what i mean it's like you
wouldn't
like a modern movie well i mean you know
well it depends on what you're talking
about
and you know so you do need some time
and you can debate all you want about
you know how long a time you need like
with characters before you start to care
about them
sometimes you spend a lot of time with
characters and you still don't care
about them
um which you know is probably if i don't
know if it's
it's hard to say that it's like you know
a failure of the filmmakers it might
just be the person watching it because
other people might relate i think a lot
of it is
i think a lot of it is the era in which
it was it was made i mean
you look at you look at
amityville horror the original
i saw it in the theater was that when i
was a kid and just [ __ ] loved it
we thought it was a [ __ ] scary movie
yeah i thought it was scary too
yeah it's kind of long and slow and
there's nothing real special about it
when you look at it today
you can actually watch like an episode
of the haunting from the 90s and then
and it's better just an episode of the
haunting might actually be better
he'd saw that as a kid in its place
you'd have been even more
impressed you know what i mean if you've
brought that back in time when you were
a kid
now they come out with a movie it's not
going to be edited and shot the way
amityville horror is it's going to be
like something out of the conjuring
universe
yeah and the conjuring universe is kind
of like an episode of the haunting on
steroids
yeah it's even more intense yeah and uh
it's even
faster paced and there isn't a lot of
characterization in acting in the
goddamn thing it's a damn haunted house
it's a haunted house movie yeah that's
what it is it's just like going through
the ride at disneyland through the
haunted house the haunted mansion
it's just more scarier it's about as
much imagery
there's story there but it is a very
simple story compared to say like
the dialogue out of the [ __ ]
interestingly i i don't know because i
think i brought up uh
dance macabre before the stephen king
book and i've read it like probably a
million times because i thought it was
like really good it's a if you don't
know it's a nonfiction book and he wrote
it
about um kind of the history of horror
he was almost
it wasn't even like essentially a
history he was kind of like you know
talking about horror it was
he was teaching it at the time he was
teaching a course in horror and
literature
uh in movies so it's kind of like that
so it was like from 1950 to 1980
although he talked about like some
classics of literature as well
we talked about books movies tv
everything and he
was saying something about the
amityville horror that really stuck with
me
he said when he first saw it in the
theater
that one of the things that really
struck him about it was that
a lot of the [ __ ] that's in it that you
maybe think doesn't have anything to do
with the haunted mansion
uh you know the haunted house or
whatever he's like it's almost kind of
like trying to make you relate to these
characters because it's
an economic he calls it an economic
horror yeah there's not much there well
no
not in that sense he means that um
because
all of this [ __ ] happens like these this
family the lutz family moves into the
house
and they clearly don't have a [ __ ] ton
of money because they have a bunch of
kids
and so there's a lot of scenes in it
like a lot of the [ __ ] that the
supernatural [ __ ] that happens
has to do with the house getting wrecked
like the front door being blown up
like all the money going missing like
all that kind of stuff so he's like in
that way you can relate to it in an
economic sense yeah and he said that
when he saw it in the theater
um somebody in front of him even said
think of the bills
yeah like that was the first thing they
were thinking of and he's like well that
that's a successful like way of getting
to her because that's something that a
lot of people can relate to
yeah you know what i mean because this
family didn't have a lot of money and
like their whole house was like being
wrecked around them and they had to pay
for it presumably
now i remember after we saw that one
kimmy took me to see another one later
on it was
the evil yeah which was that was several
years later i think
so that was seven no it no the evil
was before was it before the evil i
think was 1978
uh-huh i think and amityville horror was
79.
okay so imagine this i think all right
the evil might have been 81 but i'm
pretty sure it felt 78 i was pretty sure
it was 78
yeah maybe i thought it was after but
you know i was i was a kid
yeah so she took me to see that one too
and um yeah it might have been right
around the same time it was very
different
i thought that was a lot more intense
than amityville horror i thought was
scarier
back then i look at it now and i was
like no that's not very scary actually
it was
amityville was more scary it was it was
a little slower
yeah and it like you said it built up
all that tension and stuff
and there was a lot more mystery in it
the evil actually showed you a lot
people being picked up by ropes and hung
and people being electrocuted and
a guy get you know dead guy in a box and
people getting sucked in to get people
getting burned up by the furnace
so there wasn't very much mystery in it
but i remember it being intense these
new like uh
bloom house or [ __ ] conjuring um
these conjuring uh universe movies are
more like the evil
yeah yeah i mean like a haunted house
ride i mean the first conjuring
actually was pretty was fairly
restrained at least from what i remember
yeah um you know which i think works
better in horror up to a point
you know what i'm saying you said the
evil was 78 yeah that's what i did yeah
okay i said it was nine yeah
it came out the year before anybody evil
horror because i'm pretty sure anybody
below 79.
um yeah is it i think the thing that i
liked about amityville
um that made it scarier one was you know
the
thing about this poor family like
financially going down the drain too but
also
of the the scary idea of the husband
being
taken over essentially by a demonic
force or the ghost of the murder of
ronnie defeo or whatever
and of you living in a house with
somebody that you think is maybe like
going crazy and
might chop your head off with an axe
that's pretty scary and um
i remember when i was a little kid
what's the scene that scared me most of
all
was uh when margot kidder goes
up to uh her daughter's room and
she and the little girl saying she was
talking to jody and then she sees the um
the rocking chair like rocking back and
forth and then she sees those eyes out
the window ooh that used to freak me out
when i was little
that was a giant pig they don't and i
don't even think they ever show the
vagina pig
i mean she just describes her as a big
pig right oh well they showed the eyes
and outlines of it remember
there was like an outline of it i think
like up on the balcony like yeah when he
was out in the boat
on the boathouse he saw it looking out
through the window at him yeah that
scared me
yeah see that kind of shit's creepy but
they didn't like show it it's not like
oh
like big pig monster like in pole
because that would have been dumb
um it's creepier like just leaving it to
your imagination evil was 78 amberville
was 79.
okay my memory yeah for you guys who are
new to the show i had this uh
babysitter that lived a couple door
stores down to me when i was a kid her
name was kimmy
and kimmy looked like carrie fisher
carrie fisher she looked just like
princess leia i showed a picture of her
one time maybe i'll show it again one
time
i have family photos over around here
somewhere but uh
at that time she was probably about 14
maybe 13 14. yeah
because in the 70s um your mom would
hand you over to uh teenage girls
to watch you they probably still do that
today but yeah teenage girls were
would take care of the kids and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] but now she was that was my
first girlfriend loved it
and she then she when she hit about 16
she had like a [ __ ] 19 year old
boyfriend i was heartbroken
oh you can't compete with that yeah how
old are you in a car
maybe like 10 or 11. you're like i'm 10.
i can't drive
oh yeah in my birthday and my buddy
jimmy who's the same age as me she goes
there with your girlfriend there goes
your girlfriend
poor baby he's got a camaro i was like
oh
yeah [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] had
a camaro
oh my god i just went when you were
talking about young man it starts early
when you were talking about him i
pictured him as like john travolta's
[Laughter]
she's walking out with him goodbye tommy
you know it's like oh my
oh oh there's she's like i love you
there she goes and running
dude ran off in the car to get some ass
[Laughter]
poor baby time
i was thinking the other day because i
was thinking about brian de palma in the
context of this movie
and i don't think that we've ever
reviewed the original carrie have we
interestingly so we should probably get
around to that one of these days
now i did not know until today because i
know i think it was esther that asked
like right before
like we started even talking that uh
asking if anybody had seen the remake of
sisters
and i was like you know what until today
i didn't even know that there was one
like i knew that there was there's other
movies called that but they're not
the same movie but i guess in i think it
was 2014
i guess they did a remake of this i
think chloe 70 was in it
and i was just kind of like now i kind
of want to see it although i never heard
anything about it so it can't have been
that [ __ ] fantastic
but um i mean it's a good story you
could totally remake this
yeah nowadays you know
just without that terrible hair margo
kitter's hair looked okay
but that i thought they remade carrie
several times already no i'm not talking
about carrie i'm talking about sisters
oh sister sorry
they did ra they did rematch carrie um
i'm getting confused
it was i think uh what's her face was in
it um
chloe grace moritz she i think she was
in it the first one you know what um
am i thinking that or was she in the
second with carrie two the rage or
whatever the [ __ ] it was
i remember seeing one of them and
thinking well that wasn't as bad as i
was expecting
but i don't really remember much about
it either yeah um
so you know i i kind of feel like that
was one of the ones that they just
should have left alone
because that was it was good you know
yeah if you're going to remake a movie
take like a shitty one
or one that was a good idea but poorly
executed at the time because they didn't
have the budget or whatever
and do that i don't know i don't i don't
know why they insist on like remaking
good movies i'm like they did it they
already did a good one
don't do it again you know what i'm
saying yeah yeah all right
yep uh 60's ram says i've seen the
remake it's really not that great yeah i
figured
i figured it wouldn't be i mean this one
is just so
i mean it's very 70s but there's
something very kind of like
just cool and distinctive about it like
i said i love all the split screen stuff
i love the bernard hermann score because
it's totally like over
over the top and like melodramatic and i
love that and uh i don't know it's just
it's weird it's a weird [ __ ] flick
and like i said i really like that long
hypnotic sequence at the end this is
like totally
creepy and weird uh sister's remake is
on shutter uk not sure about the us
version
yeah i think that you guys have the
original version on shutter uk too
because that was where i noticed it
um but i don't have the vpn on our xbox
like in the other room
so um unless i wanted to watch it on my
laptop in the office because i do have a
vpn on this so i can watch uk shutter on
this computer
but we wanted to watch it in there on
the big tv so we just watched it on
amazon prime we just paid four bucks to
run it
you know what i mean to get the
criterion thing but yeah i think both
versions are on the
uk shutter i don't know i might get
around to watching it one of these days
but
i have a whole bunch of other movies i
gotta watch t says they better not
remake exorcist yeah they they shouldn't
even [ __ ] with that
don't even try well didn't they make
like a bun well they made a bunch of
sequels and prequels and
we saw we saw didn't we see a mexican
one that was a lot like
it was like i said well if there was
going to remake the exorcist that it
would be like that
what remember that we saw the cup couple
years back i can't remember now it was
pretty good
yeah yeah i think it was mexican well i
can't remember you remember no yeah
it was pretty good we've seen a lot of
stuff in the last few years yeah
taylor says sisters is in my top 25
horror movies of all time
it's really really good and i just kind
of i don't know i just feel like it
doesn't really get
i hardly hear anybody bring it up i
think i watched it like five or six
years ago maybe longer
because i saw it on a like an underrated
horror movies
list because i you know periodically go
through those in case i missed something
and i was like oh brian de palma it's
like i've never heard of that one so i
went and watched it and i was like wow
that's pretty awesome i don't know why i
never heard of it before
so but it's one that still doesn't
really get talked about i guess it's got
a little bit of a cult following but not
as much as some of the other ones
yeah dermot says the fog and the wicker
man remakes were terrible yeah agree
i saw the remake of the fog well i saw
the wicker man too that which was
unintentionally funny that remake of the
fog was
garbage awful garbage it was awful
i couldn't believe it was that bad
actually it was just a random movie that
they called the fog
i kind of feel like that happens a lot i
feel like there are generic
like horror movie scripts kind of
floating around and
i think like a studio get hold and be
like well this is kind of like some
random ass [ __ ] that wrote this
there's no names attached to it so let's
attach it to an already
kind of known ip so we'll just kind of
tweak it a little bit
so it sort of fits and we'll call it
that it had absolutely no
artistic value no none at all that
wasn't even
art yeah it was just lame yeah terrible
it was just lame terrible but you know
what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do not much just
don't just not watch it that's what
you're gonna do
just watch the original did i like the
halloween remake
the rob zombie one no i didn't see it i
didn't like it
um like i said some of it was okay but i
thought i
really really i you know i like rob some
of rob zombie [ __ ] like i liked house of
a thousand corpses and all that but it's
like when he remade halloween
i was like why on earth would you want
to demystify michael myers like that
remember like oh he was just an abused
child and whatever it's like i don't
want to sympathize with michael myers i
just want him to be like a scary
boogeyman we saw the last
halloween in the theaters it had um
curtis yeah that had
curtis in it and uh i did i forgot it
instantly it was that right
it was just it was mediocre who was that
right i had never really seen halloween
one or two
up until recently i still don't remember
a bunch of bottoms they didn't make a
big impact on me
the one that i had i saw constantly in
the day that it came out was halloween
three
seasons and for me that was the first
halloween movie that i saw
so i didn't have any preconceived notion
of what a halloween movie was
and i liked that movie i still like
halloween they're weird i love it
plus a lot of kids get killed in it yeah
it has nothing to do with michael myers
and
i didn't know there was anything to do
with michael myers at the time that i
saw it
so i just i saw it as a stand-alone i
loved it with the [ __ ]
three more days through halloween silver
shamrock like [ __ ] in the [ __ ] kid's
head explodes and a bunch of crickets
roaches and slugs come out and yeah
snakes come out and kill the mom and
everything i was just i just thought it
was awesome
and she was messing around with that
little silver shamrock disc
with a bobby pin and it blew up and shot
her in the mouth and a potato bug came
out and i was just oh yeah
i had no idea what i was watching
there's some crazy [ __ ] in that one i
really liked it yeah and the guy had a
heart
army of androids and he's [ __ ] got
stonehenge with him and he's i mean it's
just it's
such a batshit idea [ __ ] crazy i know
loved it but it had a weird alien
feeling
to it it was almost kind of like
something about a video drum or the
brood
you know what i mean like a like a um
like a what's his name movie like a
david cranberry like a cronenberg movie
where it was just
cronenberg was always talking about some
weird institute
or some weird company or some weird
group that was doing something weird and
it was like that
it was actually they have a little bit
of a chronometer like a cronenberger
that's how i saw it because i saw those
movies all the same around the same era
the brood video drone and halloween
three
that was around the same area i was
watching them and i just thought that's
the way a horror movie should be
it should be some weird institute doing
some weird [ __ ] and
people bumble into it and they go wow
you know
wow this is some weird [ __ ] wow they're
they're they're they're blowing up
stop it stop it stop it
you know they're controlling bums with
televisions
you can't tell as one does yeah illicit
porn coming through the cable through
satellites says she's never seen video
jerome
oh no you got to see videos
you got to see video drama yeah video
classic yeah
i mean deborah harry from blondie's in
it
um it's got a lot of [ __ ] bondage and
s m and
vagina control that comes through
um video signals and it's
weird but it is very very cool very cool
way ahead of its time
it was and um it takes a while to
understand what the movie is
about you're going wait a minute what
the hell's happening
um it's a little easier to understand
now
but maybe not really because i think a
young person
probably wouldn't understand the grasp
of how video changed things
yeah this movie is about the emerging
video technology
yeah early 80s early 80s yeah right
and there was a big difference between
video technology and film
it opened up new possibilities for
underground recording
and broadcasting yeah and the the
emergence of
cable television and satellite signals
that could broadcast
video that was that was like the
internet of the age
of the era yeah there's another weird
movie
that that [ __ ] influenced me a lot
have grown up in a military academy
it was about a kid in a military academy
that uses an apple 2e computer to summon
the devil
evil speaker called evil speak i [ __ ]
loved it with clint howard
clint howard i love ron howard's brother
yeah because he was really nervous
we didn't really know what was possible
with a [ __ ] computer a lot of people
didn't really know what a computer
was for i kind of loved so many horror
movies in the 80s they're like yeah i'm
just going to use this little apple 2e
computer with like
three you know [ __ ] did not even bk
like 3k or whatever yeah and i'm going
to summon demons and everybody's like
yeah
yeah they were picking some some of the
students in the in the academy were
picking on him because he was
kind of a [ __ ] beta so he summons
demons to
to get the power of the [ __ ] satan
and he becomes like a [ __ ]
satanic ubermensch it's [ __ ] great
man really good
i like i like that they they actually
talked about that movie a little bit on
the new um in search of darkness
documentary
because like i said this one is part two
so they're in search of darkness so
they're kind of going into like a little
bit more obscure movies
so they actually did talk about evil
speak on there ramon asked about uh
cronenberg's dead zone which is also an
amazing amazing
we actually reviewed that one a long
time ago that might have been one of the
first ones that we did
now that i'm thinking i still got a big
soft spot for for the brood though from
cronenberg
that was a weird movie well like you
said those little kids in their little
feety pajamas coming after you
pajamas little drone children
and like i said that scene where she's
called a baby she's like licking all
she's like
she's like she's like a queen aunt
popping out all these little [ __ ]
fatherless children that go out and
[ __ ] they're
psychically linked with her obeying her
commands
it was all done through like the power
the
the power of [ __ ] suggestion through
the mind and the subconscious she was in
this
new age religion where they were the
mind was controlling the body and
trying to resolve [ __ ] inner
conflicts
from your past it's [ __ ] cronenberg
you know
cronenberg did he was cool he would and
and his son from the movies that i've
seen
his son is the same way he he's coming
yeah we did we reviewed possessor yeah
and i actually interviewed
um anti-viral so i think that's gonna go
up
thursday i did a review of that that was
on uk shutter so i watched it on there
that was his first movie i think
i think possessor is only the second one
but he has a lot of the same
um you know obsessions
as his dad does you know what i mean
weird things that the body can do
you guys video [ __ ] how does that
affect the body
and the mind and that's what that's what
video drum is
you need to see that one t video drum
[ __ ] right
yeah just kind of well and kind of like
like i said you know when we grew up
there was all these kind of like because
you know there was all that kind of [ __ ]
with
faces of death and like it was a snuff
movie and
like underground videotapes and [ __ ]
because like i said that was like a new
thing
yeah what does that do to your mind you
know and so so i think that he played on
that really well
because so i don't know how it you know
i don't know how it plays today but
i got the criterion edition of it yeah
and it looks really good
and deborah harry from blondie is in it
yeah she co-stars at it she does a
really good job
she plays it and she plays it straight
you know
she's very believable she doesn't she
doesn't seem like she's just some rock
star that they put in a movie she's
like a an actress a real actress yeah
and she's [ __ ] obsessed with [ __ ]
bdsm and stuff
pain it's pretty cool yeah that was a
good ass flick
yeah all right we have anything else we
need to add
we can shut it down yeah because we've
been going more than an hour you got to
make those you got to get on those
screens man
yeah you need to get on that
all right so we will be back tomorrow
we kind of decided yeah if we're going
to do another movie review or we're
going to do a food show we'll figure it
out
sometime before we go on so have a good
rest of your day you guys thanks
everybody for dropping by
and chatting with us and uh we will see
you guys again tomorrow
bye